oui bonjour jimmy bonjour à tout le
monde bonjour lui dit à beaulieu bonjour
merci d'être dans ce studio ce matin en
tant que référente territoriale de la
république en marche en martinique et
donc soutien affiché du candidat
emmanuel macron nous vous avions reçu
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas longtemps ici il
y a quelques jours juste un peu après
que emmanuel macron avait annoncé sa
candidature mais nous n'étions pas
entrer encore dans la nouvelle période
du décompte des temps de parole
politique pour cette campagne électorale
et donc ça commençait le lendemain
d'ailleurs de votre présence ici est
donc c'est pourquoi vous vous retrouvez
quelques jours après a à nouveau ici
puisque nous vous à nous avons lancé une
invitation à la république en marche
martinique à la rue en martinique et
entre vous avez décidé que c'est vous
qui reviendrait voilà on devait cette
explication quand même à nos auditrices
et nos auditeurs qui aurait pu dire bah
tiens à l'été lie à peine quinze jours
elle revient voilà rappelez nous
pourquoi vous jeune martiniquaise avait
choisi d'avoir rejoint les rangs de la
république en marche alors c'était en
2017 à l'époque j'étais us à une simple
citoyen engagé on va dire relativement
éloigné des questions politiques en
dehors des des élections et puis il ya
eu cette élection majeure de 2017 où on
avait un candidat qui créa la surprise
qui avait un vrai discours qui m'a parlé
notamment sur sur l'emploi sur quelle
quelle place de la france en général et
de nos outre mer en particulier au sein
de ce nouveau monde qui est en train de
se dessiner et dont on n'a pas encore
tous les contours nets et donc j'ai
décidé je me suis je ne me suis pas
engagé bille en tête rejet j'ai pris le
temps de la réflexion à peu près deux
mois quand même avant de m'engager et de
demont cartes et chose que je n'avais
jamais fait jusque là évidemment vous
êtes là aujourd'hui pour défendre le
candidat mais neil mac ont donc on
comprend bien que vous n'êtes pas déçu
pour votre part personnelle mais
certains disent que durant ce
quinquennat c'est cinq ans les
territoires d'outre-mer ont été les
grands oubliés les abandonner même de la
république française alors abandonné
n'est pas le terme je suis pas d'accord
avec ça puisque c'est vrai que l'on a
souvent tendance à se penser comme
entité
presque isolée du reste du territoire
national mais il faut quand même se
rappeler que
l'essentiel puisque nous sommes
département l'essentiel des
dispositifs nationaux s'applique
s'applique chez nous en particulier pour
les dispositifs sociaux tous les
dispositifs qui ont qui touchait au
salaire je vais pas tout énumérer mais
par exemple on a les heures
supplémentaires exonérées la prime pour
l'emploi et cetera et cetera la
suppression de ça c'est possible il ya
volleyeuses hausse n'est pas nouveau ça
s'applique que presque s'est
pratiquement tarie encore dans l'article
73 de la constitution française oui mais
voyez ce que je veux dire que méchant
qu'on croit je pompe à yahia c'est le
décalage de perception en fait on a le
sentiment que parce que il n'ya pas
d'aidé des mesures spécifiques à nos
territoires que nous sommes abandonnés
alors qu'en fait nous faisons nous
faisons partie intégrante de ce
territoire de ce grand territoire
national alors peut-être que il y à un
effort à faire je le reconnais sur la
communication sur expliquer tout ce que
nous faisons tout ce qui s'applique
aussi à nous et le président aussi l'a
reconnu qu' il comme j'aime à dire nous
avons des marges de progression n'y a
pas de l'indifférence un peu par moment
peut-être parfois deux de l'exécutif
d'une manière générale du principe même
du conseiller du gouvernement de
certains ministres des l'indifférence je
ne crois pas en tout cas c'est pas c'est
pas mon ressenti
de la méconnaissance plus exactement
c'est vrai que mais on ne peut pas quand
on est dans un dialogue on ne peut pas
reprocher à un des deux deux
interlocuteurs
de ne pas comprendre si on ne lui
explique pas donc je crois qu'il ya
vraiment une importance à créer un lien
entre nos territoires il était alors ça
sert sur la forme comment se déroule la
campagne en martinique la campagne pour
emmanuel macron on sait qu'il ya
plusieurs comités de soutien qui se sont
constitués bon voilà à sainte-marie le
maire a voulu faire le sien je crois que
le maire de saint pierre a le sien celui
de case-pilote ralph montplaisir qui
s'affiche aussi en soutient emmanuel
macron alors voilà on a l'impression que
ça patine un peu non alors c'est vrai
que c'est une organisation on va dire
atypique en fait au niveau national il
ya eu cette volonté de faire une
campagne peut-être plus de proximité
donc
étant donné alors ça c'est une période
qui était antérieure à la déclaration
enfin la candidature logiciels et donc
il nous a fallu trouver nous a fallu
être inventifs pour pouvoir faire
campagne sans véritablement avoir de
candidat et donc cette création de
comités de soutien c'était
une façon de dynamiser nos réseaux
d'élus mais là on va voter dans quoi
moins de quinze jours maintenant on
n'entend pas parler de grandes réunions
de travail on nous travaillons à une
beau rassemblement nous travaillons
aussi à nous nos actions de proximité
style tractage chose comme ça donc oui
on est dans les starting blocks et là
tout se met en place on espère aussi de
belles surprises mais pour le moment je
ne peux pas en dire pis alors emmanuel
macron est intervenu dire à la télé dans
l'émission outre-mer 2022 qui était
d'ailleurs diffusé un ici donc sur notre
antenne télévision télévisée plus tôt et
voilà est donc en parlant du chômage il
avance et je le cite un
le chômage on a baissé de 4 à 5 points
le chômage dans les antilles he
makes au hockey ou edward commentaire
oui mais
voilà est ce que c'est bon voilà est-ce
que c'est pas un peu prétentieux vous
pensez que oui prétendre que c'est pas
le discours qu'on l'entend oui c est
toujours un décalage entre la réalité de
ressenti mais plutôt de l'exode des
jeunes oui mais alors et à deux
problématiques on a peut-être diminuer
diminuer le chômage de 4 à 5 points ne
n'occulte pas le fait qu' il est
toujours très élevé par rapport au
niveau national donc c'est pour ça et
même quand on diminue en grande
propension quand on part de très haut et
le corps est totalement voilà on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il y à il y a eu des
effets et c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
nous continuions ce qui a été entamé et
peut-être aussi quand on ouvre le champ
de ce que nous avons fait jusqu'ici
alors autres thèmes abordés et qui
évidemment dans l'esprit de beaucoup des
lecteurs et lectrices et le pouvoir
d'achat la lutte contre la vie chère
alors emmanuel macron a dit que bon on a
essayé d'y répondre enfin il a essayé
d'y répondre avec son équipe il constate
qu'effectivement il ya encore toujours
beaucoup de produits importés et donc
que la problématique
il reconnaît que le problème reste
quasiment entiers et qu'il faut donc
aider à produire davantage dans les
outre mer alors bien sûr vous êtes
d'accord mais comment ça se passe est ce
que justement il y aura un plan par
rapport à ça parce qu on parle beaucoup
et puis il ya peu d'action notamment
pour des fois aller contre les
puissances économiques contre un certain
lobbying qui se fait directement à paris
alors il faut quand même rappeler que
cette question du pouvoir d'achat c'est
c'est c'est pas nouveau et nous avons
déjà enfin ça ça fait plusieurs années
que on essaye de trouver des solutions
donc malheureusement il n'y a pas de
recette miracle sinon je crois quoi on
aurait déjà trouvé il ya un ensemble de
mesures
qui qui faisaient déjà dont certaines
faisaient déjà partie des objectifs pour
le quinquennat qui s'achève mais encore
une fois la crise sanitaire notamment a
beaucoup contrarié l'avancée de ces
projets là mais il a avancé au mieux
pour l'avenir médias oui là il a avancé
tout interdit parce que lui-même il dit
dans une sorte de mea culpa je n'ai pas
été assez vite et pas assez fort il faut
aider donc davantage les nouveaux
acteurs il faut mettre plus de
concurrence oui
par exemple vous allez faire pression
sur le candidat emmanuel macron pour que
ce soit effectivement plus plus concret
et qu'on passe un autre braquer dans
cette question la vie chère je ne crois
pas qu'on ait besoin de faire pression
sur le
gesppe futur président il ay l'aller les
problématiques sur la table il fait des
propositions
évidemment que nous serons attentifs à
ce que ce soit que les engagements pris
soient tenus mais encore une fois sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat on ne peut
pas agir sur un seul
par exemple si on dit que on veut
travailler sur les prix ça ne sera pas
suffisant il faut aussi travailler sur
les revenus il faut aussi travailler sur
nous des nouveaux modes de consommation
il faut travailler sur quel quel futur
pour notre énergie et toutes ces
questions d'autonomie voilà avant-hier
autonomie alors autonomie économique
mais autonomie politique on va conclure
là dessus
alors les adaptations institutionnelle
le président sortant donc qui se
représente il dit attention parce que
c'est important donc on comprend qu'il
est peut-être ouvert à certaines
évolutions mais avec ce principe qui
décident paye qui paye décide voilà donc
je ne veux
c'est au gouvernement de payer mais pas
tout le temps non donc oui il est ouvert
à l'adaptation institutionnels pour
déverrouiller quand c'est nécessaire
faut que ça réponde aux besoins du
territoire mais ça veut dire en même
temps peut-être moins de moyens de
l'état l'autonomie c'est aussi apprendre
à se débrouiller un peu plus par soi
même et en produisant davantage aussi
c'est la fameuse c'est la fameuse règle
de droit et devoir il faut un moment
donné il faut savoir être cohérent et
honnêtes avec nous mêmes soit on décide
que nous voulons être autonome et à ce
moment là on prend ses responsabilités
soient nos acceptant de d'être plus
étroitement liée au territoire national
et à ce moment là on accepte aussi les
règles mais moi je crois et le président
l'a dit aussi la question de l'autonomie
ou des statuts doit être une question
mise sur la table uniquement si derrière
il y a un intérêt il y a un avantage
pour dans le quotidien de tout un chacun
si si on peut avec les moyens actuels
améliorer la vie de nous de nos
concitoyens il n'y a pas je vois pas
l'intérêt de repartir sur ce type de
mercy lydia beaulieu vous restez avec
nous en studio pour la séquence des
questions tout